we're going to move their plane do me a
favor step out of the car turn off the
vehicle and step out yes
sir you have any guns knives drugs bombs
anything crazy in the car okay ma'am I'm
talking to her not you step over here
yes
sir step right to the front of this
car how much you had to drink today I
had a a drink at ever SE we were coming
well two two drinks okay yes sir let me
explain something there's somebody who's
been behind you stay in the
car
that's shut the door right now and stay
in the
car that's my neighbor that lives in we
live in Grassy Key okay explain yes yes
sir a car got behind you all the way
back about 99 street by the airport okay
they've been behind you the entire time
you have been reported as all over the
road I then pull into here you pull you
pull hold on you pull out of Tom Thum
without even paying attention to
oncoming traffic then you pull pull into
here make a wide right hand turn you're
driving in the hold on you're driving in
the grass right I light you up all the
way at the top of the Street then you
continue to drive down the street you
know I I know that that doesn't mean but
I was like my my friend was trying to
teach me how to back stay in the car
shut the door
now stop just stay right here okay ma'am
if I have to tell you to stop doing sh
again you know what step out Step Up
Step Up step out step out step out come
here come here come here come here come
here Touch come here ma'am turn around
turn around Touch Me Turn Around what am
I doing stop hey please so sorry it's
the fact that there's no ma'am stay
right there don't
move the you're throw you're throwing
out of the car I did not okay where'd
that come
from 4120 I have one detained can you
have my back up step it up a little bit
I'm so sorry it's not bad ma'am do you
have anything on you comeu me stop it's
really not have a seat have a seat have
a seat have a seat don't move put your
legs in the car put your legs in the car
no you're not sorry no you're not sorry
no I'm put your legs in the car put your
legs in the car put your legs in the car
okay you're this close from me taking
you to jail just shut your mouth and let
me do my job put your leg in the
car
may
I my friends live you don't have to hold
the air oh clear the air I got one
detained in the car I'm back dealing
with the driver now code five okay okay
so I came my friends live at the end
they were moving into the other house so
they have plants and we were going to
put them on uh like a little
like you know rolly thing okay to move
them to there and so that was it she's
just my neighbor that lives in grassy
cave okay and I'm sorry I don't have to
hold on on this please ma' shut your
mouth please I'm really really comt shut
your mouth all right here's my question
for you yes sir you're operating a
vehicle right it's very clear to me that
you have had way too much to drink today
okay okay you're slurring your speech I
can smell it on you your driving pattern
are that being said are you are you
willing to do some standardized field
sobriety exercises to dispel my belief
you are under the influence well I can't
go ahead and be 100% that I'm under the
influence but I can go and ahead and
tell you that I live two streets I mean
not two streets but two BL like what
street are we on right now we're on 27th
okay right here okay my my friends live
at the end and they're moving okay
you're not you're not understanding my
question here right whatever you need
need me to do are you willing to do
field sobriety exercises yes sir okay
yes sir okay all
right pleas hey ma'am my Bloods are fing
I'm sorry okay you're under arrest for
obstruction and destruction of evidence
okay then I'm loing please
okay uh Serge you help me lay this out
real quick
absolutely I can I can see it from here
yeah while walking keep your eyes on
your feet all times keep your arms down
at your sides and count your steps out
loud do not stop once you've already
begun okay if you step off the line step
back on and continue counting okay you
may begin when you're ready all right
one two three four 5 6 7 8 9
10 switch remember that turn that I
showed you and then nine steps back yes
sir I just want to make sure that that's
okay okay mhm one 2 three four five 6 S
8 9 10 okay all right last thing I going
to ask you to do face me right here come
come here face me all right put your put
your AR feet together and your arms on
your sides like this okay when I tell
you to begin only want I tell you you're
going to take your left or your right
foot whichever one doesn't matter
whatever you choose you're going to lift
that foot approximately 6 in off the
ground it's about the size of a Coke can
okay while doing this hold on stop like
this but don't start until I tell you to
while doing this you're going to count
out loud on the following man 1,1 1,2 13
and so on until I tell you to stop if
anytime you put that foot down pick it
right back up continue counting where
you left off so if I was on three it's
going to be 104 okay ready hold on while
doing this keep your eye on your toe at
all times keep your arms down to your
side and count out loud do not stop once
you've begun okay okay listen like this
we're not we're not standing like karate
kid we're standing like this okay right
yes all right yes sir you may begin arms
out your sides okay I like I like right
foot whichever foot I told you your left
or your
right I mean
I okay favor put your hands behind your
back yes you're under arrest for driving
under the influence do you
understand okay what's going to happen
from this point forward we're going to
go to the station I'm going to ask you
for a lawful sample of your breath if
you do not provide your breath your
license will automatically be suspended
for a period of one year right once you
give that once you give that response it
will be read to you verbatim if you
choose not to submit to a breath test do
you understand right well you have to
have a blood test I don't have to have
anything I have enough probable cause to
arrest you right now well I understand
okay I understand I'm not trying to be
hard to get I got you you see the shoe
you want to put your shoes back on for
me yes sir please
okay I mean yes sir yes sir I understand
put your shoes on for
me well that's not Deputy
Marino is would he mind doing the BTO
for me got are we're taking this one in
too yeah I'm taking her okay where are
you from what's your what's your
question what did you do wrong what did
you do wrong what did I do wrong what
did you do wrong okay what did I
from the getg go from the moment you
were stopped you're not listening to
what I'm telling you to do you're shut
up shut up you want the car tell me Shut
up shut up go ahead I just did put your
hands get in the car the car in the car
in the car Jesus Christ I'm doing your
order this inside
why
why this one's going to be an issue ises
just read she just needs her cuff tojust
breaking on The Brak and shubing my face
against the wall sure right just like I
raped you too right all right step back